[Musik]
vor den augen der welt wird ein land
zerstört wird ein volk gewählt
[Musik]
das ist völkermord
[Applaus]
ein eroberungskrieg zerrüttet die
ukraine und bedroht auch unsere zukunft
wir kämpfen hier auch für die freiheit
europas
als reporterin im krieg erlebe ich angst
und not und
den mut der menschen die nicht aufgeben
wollen
auch ich bin soldat
erlebe auch wut und verwüstung und
unfassbare abgründe der grausamkeit
[Musik]
hinter uns liegt eine vierköpfige
familie
[Musik]
wie kann dieser krieg zu ende gehen und
wohin würde uns führen
[Musik]
alle hände werden nun gebraucht seit ein
paar tagen ist krieg wer eine nadel oder
schere benutzen kann kommt ins
kulturzentrum und hilft beim knüpfen
knoten und nähen der tarnnetze die
können leben retten
keiner steht abseits in diesen tagen
niemand kann so tun als gehe ihm das
nichts an
freiwillige packen und sortieren und
registrieren spenden
als patrioten sind wir nun alle in der
verantwortung
die menschen bringen lebensmittel
kleidung und decken alles was
flüchtlinge gebrauchen können es wird
nicht in kleinen mengen gespendet
sondern tatsächlich kistenweise
regierung müsste
draußen am eingang werden die
lebensmittel abgegeben und umgepackt
überall im land dieselben szenen ein
ganzes volk räumt seine vorratskeller
leer um flüchtlinge soldaten und
milizionäre zu versorgen ein volk von
dem bloody mir putin gerade noch
behauptet hatte es sei gar kein
volksheld in der größten not zusammen
wie eine familie opfert eingemachtes
saucen säfte kartoffeln oder früchte
alles was den männern in den
schützengräben unterständen und den
vielen straßensperren und checkpoints
helfen kann durch die eiskalten tage und
nächte zu kommen unter der fahne und im
schutz der soeben fertiggestellten
tarnnetze bewachen sie die stadt bei tag
und nacht bei wind und wetter und lassen
keinen durch ohne papiere und angabe von
gründen
wir wissen dass unsere jungs hier und an
der front alles tun um die bevölkerung
zu schützen falls nötig werden auch die
frauen zu den waffen greifen um unser
land zu verteidigen
ein autokennzeichen von auswärts vor
allem aus dem russisch dominierten osten
kann dem fahrzeugführer schon mal eine
längere befragung einbringen denn der
feind kann überall stecken und man
erkennt ihn nicht sofort er sieht aus
wie sie kleidet sich wie sie spricht
diese sprache
und doch kann in jedem transporte eine
bombe waffen oder anderes kriegsmaterial
verborgen sein
[Musik]
die lage ist ernst wir wurden
angegriffen und wir wissen noch nicht
einmal warum
aber eins steht fest
wir werden siegen
dieser feste glaube an den eigenen sieg
den haben fast alle diese fragen ans
aufgeben denkt hier keiner im gegenteil
solche checkpoints wie hier im westen
der stadt mit ski gibt es überall in der
ukraine
die bevölkerung hat gemeinsam mit den
militärs provisorisch hier panzersperren
selbst gebastelt aus eisenbahnschienen
worauf man sich vorbereitet hier ist
natürlich auch ein einmarsch russischer
panzer und mit diesen selbst gebastelten
panzersperren will man die dann
zurückhaltend
mit aller macht greifen die russen in
den ersten kriegstagen von drei seiten
an stoßen aber überall auf widerstand
ich male mit ski 350 auto kilometer
westlich vom bedrängten keys ist noch
ruhig
[Musik]
aber der krieg ist auch hier
allgegenwärtig den krieg herrscht im
osten des landes schon seit acht jahren
und die trauer galerie in der innenstadt
hält die erinnerung an die gefallenen
wach
14.000 tote sollen es sein europa hatte
diesen krieg längst verdrängt
hier kommt der krieg und kommen seine
opfer mehrmals täglich an wenn auf dem
bahnhof die vollbesetzten flüchtlings
züge richtung polen halten
freiwillige helfer verteilen wasser und
snacks
gibt die flaschen nach hinten weiter
damit jeder was bekommt
das ist zwar babynahrung aber die macht
auch satt
stumme abschiede für unbestimmte zeit in
eine ungewisse zukunft
zig millionen das halbe land scheint auf
der flucht auf der durchreise in den
sicheren westen entwurzelt verängstigt
wer hilfe braucht aus dem ständig
wachsenden fundus der sachspenden der
meldet sich im kino der stadt das zum
verteilzentrum umgerüstet wurde
freiwillige sortieren die hilfsgüter und
sorgen dafür dass sie die empfänger
erreichen
am schalter wird der bedarf jedes
einzelnen notiert dann geht die
bestellung weiter in den vorführsaal wo
sich im halbdunkel die hilfsgüter
stapeln kleider decken handtücher und
spielzeug jeder gibt was er entbehren
kann denn jeder weiß es sind vor allem
frauen mit kindern die jetzt hilfe
brauchen
[Musik]
und frauen führen auch hier zwischen
kartons kisten und kleider stapeln die
regie
wir treffen hier so viele frauen die uns
erzählen es ist einfach für sie
wahnsinnig wichtig dass sie helfen dass
sie einfach in dieser situation nicht
nur still und untätig zu hause sitzen
etwas machen menschen unterstützen
zusammenstehen das ist im moment das was
die ukraine hier in dieser stadt sehr
bewegt ich
komme mit lubor fans gespräch die mir
dass zettel system erklärt jede notiz
mit den benötigten artikeln hier ist die
kurzfassung eines familien schicksals
dass keinen hier kalt lässt schon gar
nicht sie die noch viel mehr für die
geflüchteten unternimmt
früh am nächsten morgen besuchen wir sie
in ihrer wohnung die sie durch reisenden
familien zur verfügung gestellt hat sie
selbst hat sich bei ihrer nachbarin
einquartiert
im schlafzimmer ruhen einige ihrer
schützlinge aus dem umkämpften osten des
landes die noch heute weiter richtung
polen reisen wollen gestern abend hat
sie mit der nachbarin die nachrichten
geschaut und geweint erzählt sie
an eine lösung durch verhandlungen
glaubt sie nicht
wissen sie ich war damals bei den
protesten auf dem majdan platz dabei und
damals haben wir drei monate lang auf
eine friedliche verhandlungslösung
gewartet aber am ende wurden doch unsere
jungen leute erschossen nein ich glaube
nur an die jungs die uns verteidigen und
die am ende auch siegen werden
wir kehren zurück in unser hotel auch
das dient flüchtlingen und vertriebenen
aus dem osten als zwischenstation bei
vielen liegen die nerven blank
als ich die abreise einer familie aus
kiel im hinterhof unseres hotels filme
ist das dem vater gar nicht recht er
will nicht dass bedenken er machte sich
aus dem staub
[Musik]
nehmen sie lieber wie wir kämpfen wie
wir durchhalten ich bringe nur die
kinder und meine frau nach polen in
sicherheit und dann komme ich zurück
nach kiew und werde für die ukraine
kämpfen wir werden unsere hauptstadt
verteidigen wir geben unser land nicht
auf
für die wenigen die es sich leisten
können und die eines der begehrten
zimmer bekommen ist das hotel ja nie
soliman mit ski ein etappenziel auf dem
track nach europa
in der lobby treffe ich die junge mutter
ostpro in der ost ukraine
[Musik]
noch ist es dort ruhig aber es ist nicht
weit bis nach donetsk und hp wo die lage
jetzt sehr gefährlich ist und wegen der
kinder haben wir uns entschieden weg zu
gehen
aber dann beendet ihr sohn mischa das
interview aus gutem grund man hört doch
mal
die sirene
da müssen wir in den keller und uns so
lange verstecken bis die sirenen nicht
mehr halt das ist jetzt für keller in
den jetzt alle gäste des hotels
untergehen müssen
ja das ist jetzt hier mittlerweile für
uns alltag hätte ich mir auch nicht
vorstellen können das noch mal in dieser
form zu erleben aber die fliegeralarm
jetzt in ihrer häufigkeit zu und jetzt
müssen wir erstmal hier im keller
bleiben
jederzeit und überall kann der
zermürbende sirenen klang auch unsere
arbeit unterbrechen und alles zum
stillstand bringen auch weit weg von der
front ist keiner vor russischen
marschflugkörpern sicher
hier überrascht uns der luftalarm im
baumarkt und auch dort müssen alle auf
schnellstem weg in einem mehr oder
weniger sicheren raum und auf entwarnung
warten
kein wunder dass jede chance genutzt
wird um die nato zur schließung des
ukrainischen luftraums zu drängen
werbeflächen an der hauptstraße als
hilferuf
und wenn wir das fernsehteam aus einem
nato statt auf der straße erkannt werden
dann bekommen wir die verzweiflung und
den unmut zu spüren
wir verteidigen jetzt ganz europa gegen
diesen putin gegen die unterjochung
gegen diese mörder
und damit schützen wir auch sie
und da sollten sie alle mögliche hilfe
leisten militärische materielle alles
nur erdenkliche sollten sie tun um die
ukraine zu verteidigen aber
hoffnungen auf ein eingreifen macht sich
keiner besonders nicht wer sich wiederum
im kino der stadt was er gemeldet der
registriert die freiwilligen für den
kriegsdienst lehrer ärzte architekten
alle berufsgruppen sind vertreten sagt
cg und alle wollen so schnell wie
möglich an die front
die stimmung blendend sagt er mit der
ukrainischen version des victory
zeichens dem dreizack seine generation
wuchs in der sowjetunion auf jetzt ist
er mit den russen fertig
doch nur gott kann denen verzeihen
viele suchen trost und halt im glauben
in dieser schweren zeit bis vor ein paar
jahren beteten russen und ukrainer noch
zum selben gott aber dann trennte sich
die hiesige kirche vom putin treuen
moskauer patriarchats
scheinbar ist der abgrund zwischen
beiden ländern nicht mehr zu überbrücken
[Musik]
wir verlassen mit ski und fahren nach
osten richtung wohl besser
[Musik]
500 km durch ein land dessen reichtum
der flüchtige blick gar nicht erfassen
kann
die fruchtbare schwarze erde die langsam
aus der winterstarre erwacht könnte
viele völker ernähren
jetzt bleiben die felder unbestellt und
bald wird die welt spüren was es
bedeutet wenn hier kein weizen mehr
wächst
[Musik]
während sich nach vier kriegswochen die
russische armee wie ein wundbrand von
den rändern nach innen frist bäumt sich
das land auf und schützt sich hinter
betonsperren und panzer fallen wie hier
auf der strecke nach nikolov und odessa
[Musik]
beim örtchen bosniers entkam der
russische angriff zumindest vorerst
abrupt zum stillstand
wir sind die circa 90 kilometer von
nikolai sch entfernt und die russischen
panzer sind bis hier vorgedrungen wir
können das mal zeigen die standen hier
kurz davor dann hat die ukrainische
armee hier diese brücke gesprengt um sie
im prinzip daran zu hindern weiter hier
in die nächste stadt vorzudringen
alles ist hier vermint ist es hier kaum
noch möglich sich frei zu bewegen auch
die anwohner müssen jetzt hier alle zu
fuss über diese kleine brücke hier gehen
man kann sich vorstellen dass natürlich
die leute alle hier in großer aufregung
sind dass die armee auch bist und
deshalb vordringen könnte aber man hat
uns hier versichert vorerst sind die
russen die russischen panzer hier
gestoppt worden
die spuren der kämpfe sind an der straße
und in der siedlung überall zu sehen
die wird man schnell beseitigen können
viel länger werden die menschen brauchen
das trauma der gewalt und der zerstörung
zu überwinden als der krieg plötzlich
über ihre kleine friedliche welt
hereinbrach
[Musik]
langsam kommt das leben auf dem
wochenmarkt wieder in gang aber alle
bewegen sich ein bisschen wie in
zeitlupe
denn der schlimmste schrecken ihres
lebens steckt noch allen tief in den
knochen
mit mann und tochter hatte sich nadia
hinter ihrem sofa versteckt und doch
kurz den mut gefunden mit dem handy
diese aufnahmen zu machen die panzer
waren in ihrer straße aufgefahren und
schossen die ganze nacht
wir haben schlimme dinge gesehen als es
endlich vorbei war sind wir raus und auf
der straße lagen lauter leichen manche
ohne köpfe und anderen waren die beine
abgerissen das war ganz schrecklich
meine tochter sie ist 13 die hat das
auch alles gesehen und seit diesem tag
ist sie ganz verschlossen und will nicht
mehr sprechen
besonders schlimm war es für die die
jenseits der zerstörten brücke im umland
leben einfacher arme bauern die selbst
nichts zu verschenken haben und denen
die fremden soldaten noch die einfachen
leben häuser zerschossen haben sowie
nadia die bäuerin die den verlust ihrer
haustür zu beklagen hat der panzer stand
auf der anderen seite sagt sie
der suchte deckung und setzte einfach
zurück wobei er dann das dach und das
rückwärtige fenster zerstört
die haben uns alle decken abgenommen und
alle kisten nach draußen gebracht
sie haben auch hier drinnen alles kaputt
gemacht das haus ist hin die wände sind
kaputt und der putz kommt herunter
hier im schlafzimmer habe ich das
fenster mit holz abgedichtet und von der
decke ist auch das holz heruntergekommen
die nachbarn hatten tags zuvor ein
schwein geschlachtet und wollten sich
geradezu tisch setzen
und da tauchten diese blutsauger auf
das handy abgenommen und uns aus unserem
haus vertrieben
als wir zurückkamen da war von unserem
schwein nichts mehr übrig und das ganze
haus haben sie auch auf den kopf
gestellt
und da kommen ihm die tränen
hinter dem hof wo die kettenfahrzeuge
den boden umgepflügt haben ließen die
russen einen toten kameraden zurück
berichtet bauer valerie
den haben sie wohl beim rangieren
übersehen jedenfalls ist ihm der panzer
über den kopf gerollt und sie haben den
toten dann einfach liegen lassen unsere
jungs haben den dann hier begraben aber
nach ein paar tagen kamen die vom roten
kreuz und haben ihn wieder rausgeholt
und mitgenommen
[Musik]
was ist das für eine armee frage ich
mich die ihre gefallenen zurücklässt wie
den müll der bleibt wenn sie längst
vertrieben sind
[Musik]
was sind das für krieger die unschuldige
ermorden und arme bauern bestehlen die
plündern und planlos zerstören
[Musik]
warum muss dieses geschundene land dem
krieg und hungersnot abermillionen opfer
abverlangten in unserer modernen zeit
noch einmal so sinnlos und zu grausam
leiden
von den trümmern der zerstörten brücke
reisen will weiter nach süden während
der angriff im norden stockt lenken die
russen die ganze wut ihrer streitmacht
auf den don bass und die region am
schwarzen meer mario pohl wird belagert
beschossen und ausgehungert ein
wichtiges ziel ist odessa
die große stadt am schwarzen meer
bekannt für ihre schönheit und ihre
leichtigkeit
ihren berühmten strand füllen sie seit
kriegsbeginn in säcken ab hunderte
freiwillige kommen jeden tag
einheimische und zugereiste kreise und
kinder es ist eine von diesen arbeiten
die alle in der bedrohung
zusammenschweißt
aber auch in der entschlossenheit sich
den angreifern nicht auszuliefern
jeder packt mit an um besser zu
verteidigen
wir unterstützen auf diese art das
militär denn jeder seins sagt kann vor
granatsplittern schützen und ein
menschenleben
wenn es nötig sein sollte würde ich mich
auch bewaffnen ja um meine heimat zu
verteidigen
putin kann sich meinetwegen unsere
schöne stadt auf einer postkarte
anschauen um mich mal höflich
auszudrücken oder sogar auf zwei
postkarten aber mehr nicht
ich lasse mich doch nicht aus meiner
heimat vertreiben nur weil die sich
irgend etwas ausgedacht haben und mich
angeblich befreien wollen bei uns ist
alles gut wir müssen nicht gerettet
werden ja ich spreche russisch und das
schon immer meine familie spricht
russisch
ukrainisch aber das russisch geht mir
leichter von den lippen
alle hier spüren diese innere
zerrissenheit mit seiner sprache sitzt
der feind in ihren köpfen
und mit den sandsäcken schützen sie auch
das russische erbe einer stadt die von
katharina der großen gegründet wurde
hier das denkmal des ersten gouverneurs
der in petersburger diensten stand
es steht am kopfende der potenten treppe
die jeder aus eisensteins berühmten
panzerkreuzer epos kennt
nicht panzerkreuzer sondern hoch moderne
kriegsschiffe liegen irgendwo da draußen
und bedrohen den größten hafen des
landes
[Musik]
das ukrainische tor zur welt ist
geschlossen
und odessa die laute die lebenslustige
steht plötzlich still
auch das hier ist und die kultur dieser
lebendigen stadt das hier zum beispiel
ist ein sex club mitten in der stadt die
st war heißt der eigentlich darf man da
erst ab 18 plus rein aber mittlerweile
dient das einfach als zuflucht wenn
bombenalarm ist dann gehen die leute da
rein so wie in ziele der klubs in der
stadt
und das trifft uns gleich auch selbst
denn schon wieder zwingt uns ein
luftalarm alles abzubrechen
unsere begleiter von der ukrainischen
armee geleiten uns in odessa unterwelt
und in eine bizarre situation
langes abwarten im rotlicht keller des
herrenclubs bis der presseoffizier von
oben endlich entwarnung gibt
[Musik]
die innenstadt ist wie eine festung
gesichert und in der hand der
verteidiger
die wachen aufmerksamen darüber dass
sich ausländische reporter nicht
selbstständig machen
das ist hier eine geführte pressetour
für journalisten den odessa drehen
möchten das organisieren sie hier
regelmäßig alleine auf sich gestellt
dafür kein journalist einfach in der
stadt drehen denn man hat große sorge
dass sie etwas gezeigt wird was für die
ukraine kriegsentscheidend ist
welche straßen noch befahrbar welche
kreuzungen und boulevards mit barrikaden
panzer regeln und stacheldraht blockiert
sind all das sollen mögliche
eindringlinge nicht schon vorher
erfahren
[Musik]
selbst die straßennamen sind unkenntlich
gemacht damit sich kein fremder hier
zurechtfinden kann
auch anwohner müssen ständig ihre
papiere vorzeigen um an den
kontrollpunkten vorbeizukommen
ein opfer dass sie ohne murren erbringen
auch wenn es manchmal umständlich ist
keiner will erleben wie in seiner
heimatstadt straßenkämpfe ausgetragen
werden
aber oft genau das bereiten sich die
soldaten vor erklärt mehr ilja der ist
23 und war vor seiner einberufung
übersetzer
und so sieht sie in der ganzen stadt aus
ja
auch diplomatie hat er studiert aber auf
verhandlungen setzt er jetzt keine
hoffnungen mehr
ich gehe jetzt um letztlich den jungs in
den ganzen leuten die hier stehen ich
glaube die werden in die stadt werden
die niemanden freilassen
auch unter einsatz seines lebens auch
hinter uns lebensjahr
wir verteidigen unser land wir
verteidigen uns recht zu sein wir wollen
das und wir stehen dafür und noch eine
unerwartete begegnung habe ich in den
barrikaden von odessa in glücklicheren
tagen die noch gar nicht so lange zurück
liegen war daniels allem ein showtalent
und star einer castingshow wie er mir
stolz zeigt
aber nun ist auch der sänger mit
libanesischen wurzeln bereit sich den
angreifern entgegen zu stellen
in der ukraine sagt er gab es früher
immer streit zwischen denen die sich
russland näher fühlten und denen die er
nach europa wollten das ist vorbei heute
sind alle vereint im kampf um die
freiheit publik
gogreen sticky die ukraine sind ein
lebenslustiges folgt das viel lacht
lachen ist unsere stärkste waffe
damit können wir unsere feinde
vernichten
darauf wollen sie ihre hoffnungen nicht
setzen
auf einem verlassenen fabrik gelände am
stadtrand treffen sich die mutigen die
wütenden und die verzweifelten zur
ausbildung am sturmgewehr
sind lehrerinnen unternehmer mütter ganz
normale bürger oder saß keiner von ihnen
hier glaubt daran dass sich dieser krieg
auf verhandlungsweg lösen lässt deswegen
wollen sie alle hier lernen sich selbst
zu verteidigen
sie glauben und fürchten dass sich ihr
krieg und ihr überleben am ende im
straßenkampf entscheiden könnte mann
gegen mann frau gegen mann sie wollen
vorbereitet sein
wenn man den finger am abzug habt dann
spürt man einen widerstand das ist der
moment in dem der schuss ausgelöst wird
und in dem die höchste konzentration
nötig ist
und hier vorne wieder bum bum und
dann schnell zurück in deckung und
die waffe beim laufen immer die höhe
halten und sicherstellen dass nicht noch
eine kugel im lauf steckt und vor allem
immer darauf achten sich selbst nicht zu
verletzen
das moderne menschen deren leben unserem
so ähnlich ist plötzlich lernen tödliche
waffen zu bedienen
das sage ich dem speditionskaufmann
alexy könnte man in deutschland im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert sicher nur
schwer vermitteln
[Musik]
kann ich nur empfehlen schaut euch an
was mit uns passiert ist das könnte euch
aufblühen und weglaufen ist keine option
jedenfalls nicht für uns
die russische armee führt nicht nur
gegen unsere truppen krieg sondern auch
gegen frauen und kinder und das bedeutet
dass sich auch die zivilbevölkerung
verteidigen muss und damit bin auch ich
eine soldaten
mit jeder horrornachricht aus mario pohl
und anderen belagerten städten wächst
ihre besorgnis doch anscheinend auch
ihre entschlossenheit so bereitet sich
die schöne stadt am schwarzen meer auf
einem sturm vor der vielleicht schon
morgen losbrechen könnte oder vielleicht
doch ausbleibt
weil es plötzlich wieder so weit
gekommen ist dass ein mann ein diktator
über das schicksal ganzer nationen
bestimmen kann
[Musik]
ein prachtbau der oper treffe ich den
sänger anatoli auch er will vor putins
truppen nicht zurückweichen das hier ist
schließlich meine heimat sagt er
ja ich kenne deutschland und daher weiß
ich was es heißt in der fremde zu leben
ich will hier bleiben
aber ich bewundere deutschlands ordnung
und disziplin
ich bewundere auch das deutsche
sozialsystem
es muss dort niemand hunger leiden und
jeder kann eine wohnung oder eine arbeit
finden und ich bin sicher so weit werden
wir in der ukraine ist auch einmal
bringen
[Musik]
unsere feinde verschwinden wie tau in
der sonne heißt es in ihrer hymne
wie hat man sie so oft gesungen und mit
so viel hoffnung
anfang april erreicht der krieg ein
wendepunkt die russen kommen verkehrt
nicht weiter der eiserne
widerstandswillen denn wir auch in
besser erlebt haben zeigt wirkung putins
armee zieht sich zurück und sucht nun
die entscheidung im don bass
und schon wagen sich die ersten wieder
zurück in die hauptstadt mutig trotzig
oder weil sie einfach nicht wissen wohin
sie sonst gehen sollen
haben sie keine angst
man hangelt sich so im zwei wochen
rhythmus vor und denkt sich noch zwei
wochen durchhalten und dann ist es
vorbei
aber dann sind zwei wochen rum und das
geht immer noch weiter
wir haben daheim in kiew für alles
stehen und liegen lassen und jetzt wo
die lage sich anscheinend beruhigt
wollen wir nach dem rechten sehen
bisher haben die russen das schienennetz
weitgehend verschont aber weil immer
mehr waffen aus dem ausland geliefert
werden ist die eisenbahn nun auch ein
strategisches ziel als es dunkel wird
schließt deshalb der schaffner
sicherheitshalber die fenster blenden
sonst sehen wir aus wie eine girlande
und sind ein leichtes ziel
dieser waggon und der da hinten sind
schon mal beschossen worden
beim nächsten stopp zeige ich ihnen die
splitter
ist nach fünf kriegswochen die stillste
und die traurigste hauptstadt der welt
verstummt ist der geschützdonner aus den
vororten aber immer noch droht
raketenbeschuss und immer noch heulen
mehrmals täglich und nächtlich die
sirenen
weshalb sich hunderte menschen vor allem
familien mit kleinen kindern in die
u-bahn geflüchtet haben sie verbringen
die nächte lieber hier damit sie die
kinder nicht ständig wecken müssen wenn
wieder die sirenen heulen
wo die bahn wagen zu herbergen werden
gelingt es nur manchmal die gedanken der
kinder wenigstens für kurze zeit
abzulenken und vielleicht aufzuhellen
und
man kann nur hoffen dass sie lange
geschützt und abgeschirmt bleiben von
den schrecken die nun ein paar kilometer
außerhalb der stadt ans licht kommen
[Musik]
wir besteigen busse der regierung unser
ziel die nord westlichen vororte kiers
die namen kennt man aus den nachrichten
und den front berichten borodjanka
espinoza
das waren bis vor kurzem beliebte
schlafstätte im grüngürtel der
hauptstadt
aber die idylle ist nicht mehr
jetzt sind die kiefer heine orte des
grauens in denen die soldaten mit einer
mordlust wüteten die unsere
vorstellungskraft sprengt
hinter uns liegt eine vierköpfige
familie die von der russischen armee
hingerichtet wurde so berichten ist die
ukraine und sie haben die weltpresse
hierhin eingeladen um zu zeigen was hier
passiert sie wollen dokumentieren welche
gräueltaten die russische armee hier
begangen hat
[Musik]
knapp vier wochen haben die russischen
truppen hier getobt bevor sie am 31 märz
wieder abzogen weil der durchbruch nach
kiew verwehrt
die presse tour in die geschundenen
vororte sie wird zum horror trip in die
tiefsten abgründe einer barbara die man
in unserer zeit nicht mehr für möglich
halten möchte
ermordete gefangenen folteropfer viele
gefesselt erschossen erschlagen und
hingerichtet in dunklen kellern auf
offener straße und in der kanalisation
jeder würde beraubt
jede für sich ein zivilisationsbruch und
erschütterndes beweismaterial für
kriegsverbrechen
putin wird der killer brigade von
butscher zum dank einen ehrentitel
verleihen
der mann also den viele politiker in
europa und auch in deutschland so falsch
eingeschätzt haben
das hält ihnen heute bitter der
ukrainische präsident selensky vor
auch er ist nach butter gekommen ich
frage ihn warum er meinte angela merkel
sollte sich das hier ansehen
ich glaube sie weiß genau was ich meine
genauso herr sarkozy
die beiden und ein paar andere waren
nämlich die maßgeblichen politiker die
damals auf der konferenz 2008 in
bukarest entschieden haben die ukraine
nicht in die nato aufzunehmen
diese entscheidung ist mit rücksicht auf
die russen getroffen worden und sie hat
die russen gestärkt
und deswegen meine ich dass die
verantwortlichen hier sehen könnten wozu
es führt wenn man nur mit den russen
solche spielchen spielt das ist alles
die kleinstadt bianca 25 kilometer von
butscher entfernt
strategisch an der fernstraße gelegen
hier entlud sich die ganze wut der
angreifer als ihr vormarsch nach kiew
zum stillstand kam
[Musik]
die südstadt berichten uns die menschen
auch hier von den gräueltaten der
russischen soldaten in welcher angst und
panik wie hier waren nur das ausmaß der
zerstörung ist hier wie man hinter mir
sieht weitaus größer als in butter
artillerie und luftangriffen trafen die
wohnblocks in denen sie nun mit bloßen
händen nach den opfern suchen und stein
für stein die ruinen abtragen es sollen
auch hier hunderte zivilisten gestorben
sein bei den bombardierungen oder
ermordet von marodierenden soldaten
die überlebenden sind zutiefst
traumatisiert
mira sucht in ihrer verwüsteten wohnung
nach überresten des haushalts mit denen
sich vielleicht ein neues leben anfangen
lässt
total aufgelöst berichtet sie von banden
angetrunken schwer bewaffnet die mit
gestohlenen autos voller diebesgut durch
die straßen kurven
da waren auch diese tschetschenen dabei
dunkle männer mit bärten und
stirnbändern immer haben sie nach frauen
gesucht die sie mitnehmen wollten
[Musik]
und sohn berichtet wie sie granaten in
wohnhäuser geschossen und frauen
entführt hätten verstehst du dass sie
stellen sich mit einer knarre im
anschlag vor dich hin und verlangen dein
auto sie würden zivilisten sie würden
ihre brüder töten für ein auto
das haus ist unbewohnbar
die waschmaschine ist heil geblieben
[Musik]
was der krieg ihnen zum leben übrig ließ
passt in einen transporter
[Musik]
happy life stand da
was heute wirkt wie kalter hohen des
schicksals das war auch in der siedlung
rp der traum von einem besseren leben
der presse begleiter der ukrainischen
armee zeigt mir was die russen von
diesem traum übrig gelassen haben
das war ein schöner neuer stadtteil eine
wohlhabende gegend es sind noch nicht
mal alle wohnungen bezogen die ersten
sind gerade angekommen und haben sich
eben eingerichtet
moderne siedlung am rande der großstadt
bequem und praktisch gute
einkaufsmöglichkeiten ideal für junge
familien
knapp vier wochen in russischer gewalt
und die schmucken eigentumswohnungen
haben sich in räuberhöhle verwandelt
schränke sind durchwühlt wertsachen
geklaut oder zerstört
müll zurückgelassen
sie haben die wohnungen ausgeraubt alle
wohnungen hier sehen mehr oder weniger
so aus das waren ihre quartiere
hier haben sie geschlafen und hier haben
sie gefeiert den schnaps haben sie sich
aus den supermärkten geholt
woher nimmt man die kraft hier wieder
aufzuräumen und neu anzufangen
julia die nachbarin ist gerade
zurückgekehrt
ich habe gerade das sofa wieder
hingestellt und die essensreste weg
geräumt sie haben alles durchwühlt und
nach geld gesucht unseren laptop haben
sie mitgenommen naja also mehr oder
weniger geht es ach ja und da das
fenster hat jetzt ein loch und unsere
tür wurde eingetreten so wie alle türen
im ganzen haus und
trotzdem will sie mit ihrer kleinen
familie bleiben wir leben ja gerne in
gruppen sagt sie
nicht aufgeben sich nicht vertreiben
lassen diese entschlossenheit spürt man
überall in den ruinen der kiewer
vorstädte als laute das allgemeine motto
jetzt erst recht
wie geht es denn weiter frage ich
alexander
wir müssen jetzt alles noch besser
aufbauen als es war und noch besser
leben als vorher und weiterhin allen
beweisen wozu wir in der lage sind
wird ihnen das städtchen am rande cats
wurde in der ganzen welt bekannt wegen
dieser brücke die hat die ukrainische
armee gesprengt um den anrückenden
russischen truppen den weg in die
hauptstadt zu versperren
[Musik]
der einzige weg für tausende
verzweifelte führte über diesen
wackligen bretter stieg auf die sichere
seite
[Musik]
über den steg in europa brachten sie
anfang märz auch hanna polonski in
sicherheit da glaubte noch niemand dass
sie überleben würde
sie war im fünften monat als sie mit
ihrem mann anton vor den russen aus
butscher flum und ihr auto fünf minuten
vom haus entfernt beschossen wurde
anton starb sofort das kind einen jungen
verlor sie
seit zwei monaten wird sie im
krankenhaus in kiew behandelt am anfang
sagt sie konnte sie gar nicht verstehen
warum die ärzte sie so besorgt
anschauten und dann in der zeit hat man
mir schon erzählt dass ich wirklich in
einem schrecklichen zustand war und dass
er es nicht so viel hoffnung gab das ich
genießen werde aber jetzt mit jedem tag
fühle ich mich schon besser
nun kämpft sich die 32 jährige zurück in
ihr leben
nicht zurückdenken nicht den schmerz
gewinnen lassen und auch nicht den hass
hass bringt nichts gutes man darf das
nicht empfinden ich möchte einfach nicht
dass
so was weitergeht ich auch für jeden tag
auf das ende dieses krieges
[Musik]
es sind begegnungen wie diese es sind
menschen wie hannah die mut machen und
die hoffen lassen und die zeigen es
braucht unfassbare tapferkeit um
unbegreifliches leid zu überwinden
verhandeln genauso wie für das ganze
land
[Musik]